the Joe Rogan experience they say that
sheep on things the hardest
they say that uh like like Alaska sheep
hunting in terms of like just the
difficulty of the terrain and the the
dangers of it yeah that somewhat yeah I
would say don't want I've only been on a
couple sheep hunts in Alaska right most
of mine have been in lower 48 or the NWT
Northwest Territories
the thing with Alaska that's easy is
you're not getting that much altitude
distance is far you're not but the
weather is bad like generally the
weather is pretty bad and then that the
amount of pressure now and again I'm not
an expert on Alaska the pressure is much
worse than it's ever been in alas in
terms of the amount of hunters hunters
yeah yeah a lot of hunters out there
yeah and then animals Grizzlies and [ __ ]
yeah which is a we've seen us get charts
on video and yes when you were at the
gritty Bowman that was terrifying
yeah that's crazy oh yeah tell me I'm an
adrenaline junkie I'll tell a true story
okay because it's not I thought like
we're calling it moose and I'm like look
in and I'm like I think there's a moose
coming and a grizzly pops out I'm like
hey get your camera let's call this
thing in it's the true story cuz we made
it sound like it was oh here comes
grizzly so I thought it was gonna get to
that [ __ ] stump and stop right you
called the grizzly in I'm please coming
into a moose call right so
oh no I'm like hey have the cameras
let's get this on video cuz he was
looking for our moose calls so this big
[ __ ] gets away that log and she stands
up she's looking around
oh cool you can hear my shutter on the
video [ __ ] it hit the ground and it was
coming and I'm like oh well and
immediately me I've been charged enough
to where I'm I'm gonna drill and junkie
anyway I'm desensitized so I'm like he's
gonna eat [ __ ] this other dude anyway
so I'm like you can see my cameras
shifting right a little as I'm taking
these photos I don't know what weapon
out of bo and so here pretty quick I'm
thinking shoot this [ __ ] it's
like 15 yards from us oh my god he fired
off a round at its feet and I knew his
gun jammed on the second round sometimes
so I'm like [ __ ] brownie a bolt doesn't
jam on the second one
whatever it was right nothing of
Browning's bad well it stopped you
remember and it came again mm-hmm I
think it's like twelve ten yards when it
finally turned off and away but ten
yards is nothing well I tell you like
mmm that's almost like that wall yeah it
was big big one but I was a B C yeah I
was in BC in in reality though you talk
to like bring up the Lancaster's if I
went with when I stayed in the NWT for
that two months timeframe mm-hmm those
guys live up there I bet if you asked a
Bart or a clay land caster how many
times they've been blessed charred left
charged
it's like triple digits like well just
hunting with those guys the [ __ ] that
they've done triple digits meaning a
hundred times at a minimum and that's
God
so like the DS like this this [ __ ] those
guys deal with they've been doing it
since birth right and so I was telling
them like like Amy and Frank I was like
okay you guys know how much I've done
and all the different thing you know
hunted how many animals I put on the
ground it's a fraction clay Lancaster's
been on 320 sheep hunts 320 that's a lot
that's not including caribou moose he's
been all over the world so the amount of
experience those guys have in the
stories like when I get those guys on
the podcast it's hilarious because I you
know I just got to experience a two and
a half month section of it we were
literally from from a light bulb from a
paved road hours from any electricity
like it's a 12 hour drive to where the
helicopter picks you up and then you're
flown in another two hours
[Applause]